we're on problem 151
if x and y are positive is the ratio of
x to y greater than three so is x the
ratio of x to y is that greater than
three and they're telling us that x and
y
are positive
fair enough statement one
x is
x is two more than three times y so x is
equal to
three
y
plus 2.
let's rewrite the original question
because i think it's going to look a lot
like this if we multiply y times both
sides equation
and we don't have to change the
inequality because they told us that y
is positive they're both great they're
both positive so if you multiply both
sides equation times y you get x
is greater than 3y that was that's this
is the same question as this
well if we look at statement one number
one clearly x is greater than three y
because x is two more than three y based
on statement number one so statement
number one is sufficient to answer this
question x is definitely greater than
three y x actually equals three y plus
two
this plus two tells you that x is that
much greater two greater
second statement the ratio of 2x to 3y
the ratio of 2x to 3
y
is greater than 2. let's just do some
algebraic manipulation 3y once again we
know that's positive so when we multiply
both sides of the equation by it we
don't have to switch the sign
so you get 2x
is equal to
is equal to 6y
now we can divide both sides by 2 and
you get oh sorry why did i put it equal
it should be greater than right greater
than divide both sides by 2 and you get
x is greater than 3y so this statement
and this statement are the same thing so
2 alone is also sufficient so either
statement alone is sufficient to answer
this or this question
okay if arc pq okay let me see if i can
draw this so they've drawn a semicircle
so let me draw a circle
that's a circle and i can make it a
semi-circle by
drawing a line
from there to
there that's about as good as i can do
and then they have it connecting to some
point
let me see if i could do this
looks like that
and then it looks like
that
and then they actually have drawn an
altitude coming down like that and i
think i'm drawing done all my line
drawing
and then this let's see they label this
p
they label this q
they label this
r
and this is 2
and they say that this distance right
here is a this distance right here
and then they say that this distance
right here is b
fair enough so they say if arc pqr so
that's that arc right there is a
semicircle what is the length of
diameter pr so they essentially want to
know what a plus b is right
they want to know what a
plus b is equal to what that's pr
so that's their question
so
immediately well let's just look at
their statements what did they give us
statement one they tell us that a is
equal to four
so from knowing that a is equal to four
if we can figure out what b is then we
would know what a plus b is and we would
be done well let's see if we can do that
statement 2
is b is equal to 1. so if we know what b
is
and then we could figure out a from it
that we know what a plus b is so
actually i think if either of these are
sufficient the one the other one
probably is because if statement one is
sufficient if a if knowing a can we can
figure out b then probably knowing b we
could figure out a but let's see if that
if that holds so one thing that i that
kind of immediately should pop out of
your head although i don't know if it
will
and this pops out of my head really from
going to math competitions when i was a
kid
but if you have a triangle inscribed in
a semicircle that triangle and one of
its sides is a diameter right and that's
the case with this one because we know
this is a semi-circle so we know that
this is the diameter
then that
triangle is a right triangle
this is a right triangle even the way
they drew it it kind of looks like that
but that's something you should know
even if this triangle was drawn like
that it's always going to be
a right triangle and i'll maybe do
another youtube video proving that but
that's just a good thing to know for the
gmat so let's see if we could use that
information and the pythagorean theorem
to come up with a formula that relates a
and b
so if we look at just this triangle let
me
if we look at just this triangle
right there
we know what we know that a
squared plus 4
is equal to let's call
the side c squared
is equal to c squared
fair enough
if we look at this smaller triangle
right here
we know that b squared
plus 4
is equal to let's call this d squared
that's the hypotenuse of the smaller
triangle is equal to
d squared
now if we look at the larger triangle
which we also know is a right triangle
now c squared and d squared are the are
the are the non-hypotenuse sides and a
plus b is the hypotenuse side so we know
that c squared
plus d squared is equal to this entire
side squared
which is a
plus b
squared
well we know what c squared and d
squared are we can substitute that so c
squared is a squared plus four and i'll
switch colors just to avoid the monopoly
so c squared is a squared plus four
a squared
plus four
and d squared is b squared plus four
right d squared is b squared plus four
plus b squared plus four
and all of that's equal to a plus b
squared let's just multiply that out
because i think we can do some canceling
so we get a squared plus two
a b
plus b squared
okay
let's see so we can subtract a squared
from both sides a squared a squared
subtract b squared from both sides b
squared and b squared
and this simples out simplifies out
quite nicely you see 4 plus 4 is 8
is equal to 2
a
b
divide both sides by 2 and you get a
b is equal to
4.
so all of this crazy information that
this is a inscribed in a semi-circle and
this is a this is b all of that reduces
down to a b is equal to 4.
so now we know if we know a
if a is four then we know that b has to
be equal to one
and so and then we can figure out what a
plus b is it's five so statement one
alone is sufficient and similarly if you
know what b is we know that a has to be
four and so a plus b is equal to 5.
so that was actually less hairy than i
thought going into it
next problem
and this really is the home stretch
does the integer k have a factor
p
such that
one is less than p is less than k does
the integer k
have a factor p
such that okay so they're essentially
saying
is k prime right this is another way of
saying is k or you could say is k not
prime k not prime or p k is composite i
think that's the word for an
a non-prime number so that's all they're
asking
does k have some other factor other than
one n itself
so let's see statement number one k is
greater than four factorial
well four factorial is four times three
times two times one so that's twelve
times two that's 24 so this rolls down
to k is greater than 24.
so i can give you both prime and
non-prime numbers greater than 24. 29 is
prime
30 is not prime
so statement one at least by itself is
pretty useless
pretty useless you can k can be greater
than 24 and be prime or not prime
statement two
this looks interesting
13 factorial which is a large number
so it's hard to multiply it out plus 2
is less than or equal to
k
which is less than or equal to
factorial plus
13.
so essentially
what we need to prove somehow is that
every number between this
and this
is not prime
let's think about how we can do it
well let's take let's let's take into
the initial example of 13 factorial plus
2.
so 13 factorial you'll just say you know
that's 13 times 12 that's 13 times 12
12 times 11. you keep going times 3
times 2 times 1. that's 13 factorial
right
so 13 factorial is definitely divisible
by 2. so we could rewrite 13 factorial
we could write that as we let's rewrite
actually this
13 factorial
divided by 2
times 2
plus 2.
i just rewrote 13 factorial plus 2. and
i want you to see that this is the same
thing right i just divided by 2 and
multiplied by 2. and you'll see in a
second why i did that
so and this is a tricky problem when i
looked at this at first which which i
actually did glance at before the video
because it seemed a little bit it wasn't
i had to think i don't know if this is
something i would have gotten right if i
was under time pressure on the gmat but
when i thought about a little bit more
it made sense
so if i divide by 2 and times 2 i could
and this actually this is going to be an
integer right because we know that 13
factorial is divisible by 2 2 is
actually one of its factors
right so as long as you understand where
i got you know third you can divide
anything by two and multiply it but you
do not change it
so this is the same thing as this
right
and then if we factor the two out if we
factor 2 out this becomes 2 times
13 factorial
over 2
plus
right i just factored the 2 out this is
this isn't a fraction that's just a line
i did just to not make it look too messy
so what we what we show is that 13
factorial plus 2 is is definitely
divisible by 2
right whatever that number is it's
definitely divisible by 2 and how do i
know that because this is just another
way of writing 13 factorial divided by
2. oh sorry this is another way let me
write this down this is the same thing
as 13 factorial plus 2.
there's just another way of writing it i
took 13 factorial divided by 2 and
multiplying by 2
and then taking out the 2.
and the reason why i know that this is
that 2 is divisible into this is because
i know that this is an integer we know
that 13 factorial is divided by 2
because 2 is one of the things that goes
into it so this is an integer you add 1
so this is an integer and so you're
multiplying 2 times some integer so this
has to be divisible by 2. so 13
factorial plus 2 is divisible by 2. now
let's just extend that generally we can
we can
13 factorial
plus x let's prove that as long as x is
less than or equal to 13 that this is
divisible by x
so we can do the same trick we say this
is equal to 13 factorial divided by x
times x plus x
that's equal to you can factor the x out
x times 13
factorial over x plus one
and how do we know that this number
which is the same thing as this number
how do we know that this is divisible by
x
well just a little thought experiment we
know as long as
we we know as long as x
is greater than or equal to 1 and less
than or equal to
less than or equal to 13 and x is an
integer as long as x is an integer
that's greater than or equal to 1 and
less than or equal to 13
it is one of the factors of 13 factorial
right 13 factorial is 13 times 12 times
11 is it's all of those numbers
multiplied together so we know that x is
as long as x is less than or equal to 13
we know that this right here this is an
integer if this is an integer then the
integer plus 1 is also an integer so 13
factorial plus x can be rewritten as x
times some
some integer i'll call it i
right
but the bottom line is the reason why i
wanted to do that it shows you that
every number between 13 factorial plus 2
and 13 factorial plus
is actually divisible by whatever number
you're adding to the factorial
so since it's divisible by those numbers
the numbers cannot be prime so hopefully
i've actually run way over time but
hopefully i've shown you that that
information alone statement 2 alone is
sufficient to show that
that
k is not prime or that k does have out a
factor p that's between 1 and k anyway i
hope i didn't confuse you that was i
think that was one of the hardest
problems we've done so don't feel bad if
you found that a little daunting see you
in the next video